Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast and
ahhh
just checking in on you. I'm
just checking in on, you know,
you're almost through the week. Some of
you get paid today. Somebody you don't,
I don't know how it fucking
works, but um, yeah,
I'm just here to check in on you
just for the fucking half an hour.
I hope you guys enjoyed the very special
edition to the Monday morning podcast
that was put out yesterday with uh,
the great,
the Great Jim Norton promoting his new
standup special that you can watch now on
Netflix. Mouthful of shame. I've heard
nothing but great things about it.
I have yet to see it because uh,
you know,
I only got so much fucking time now with
the little kid running around who just,
it just keeps getting better every day.
Just keeps getting better every day.
I Dunno what the fuck people
complain about, about having a kid.
It's fucking awesome.
Oh my God,
you going to do good as opposed to what?
Sitting alone in your apartment
do all the free time.
In the fucking world.
Slowly drinking yourself to death.
Cause I'll tell you that bit up those
sides of the fence like in this side a
little better.
Let's say in every once in awhile.
Every once in a while I don't have visit
my old friends that my fucking 83 70
sixers level bar that I have,
I always throw,
I always give a shout out to the 83 76 in,
cause every talks about the 96 bowls.
Everybody talks about the 27 Yankees.
What about the 1983
Philadelphia 70 sixers. Huh?
I would love to throw
the 86 Celtics in there,
but the fucking Lakers choked
against the Houston Rockets.
So I mean sort of a a,
you know when in the 80s it didn't mean
you didn't really feel like you won a
championship unless you beat the Celtics
and the Lakers. That's basically it.
That's, that's my, you know,
no disrespect to Ralph fucking Sampson.
No fucking disrespect.
Do Chemo [inaudible] Lucy on a
TV or they have fucking treat.
No tree Rollins was Atlanta.
I don't remember.
They had very similar uniforms
in my memory bank. In fact,
I think they had the exact same colors,
just Houston Rockets was less busy.
More traditional like the Detroit Red
Wings, jersey, simple red and white,
Toronto, blue and white sit.
It's over. These are our colors.
Fuck you somebody.
Please explain to me how the Tampa Bay
fucking lightning also can wear blue and
white. I don't understand that. You know,
it's like the Pittsburgh Penguins when
they came back wearing black and gold,
it's like what the fuck?
Bard Nick told me that the original
fucking hockey team in Pittsburgh did wear
black and gold. But then yeah, but then
you folded and you left it on the table.
It's like when you don't
renew your fucking website,
somebody else is going get it. Um,
I don't know what I'm talking about.
All I know is I have to plow through this
next fucking half an hour just to see
how you're doing. Whatever. Maybe I'm
going to catch you on the ride home.
You know, worst case scenario,
you got one fucking day left.
Use a sick day, take a three
day weekend. You know, you know,
it was actually thinking now is
this is the time of year where, uh,
the spring break,
I wonder what kids do nowadays.
It's gotta be a way where they can
get out of the view of the constant
surveillance of your parents.
Now,
you know what I mean?
Jesus Christ.
By the time my daughter
gets to that fucking age,
I'll probably be able to have a drone
like hovering over her for her the entire
fucking existence.
I'll just shout down from the sky,
you know, on a dog. Go to that
party, just freaking around.
She'd be looking up like dad,
oh,
so shaken my dad hovering over me in a
hoe and a fucking whatever the fuck it's
called. That will literally
be helicopter parenting.
No,
it's fucking drones.
I went to something recently and I guess
the gift bag was a drone. It's like,
why would you give people those things?
It's not intrusive enough.
All this fucking technology that all these
fucking Weirdos, you know what I mean?
I want to know the first time a drone
is going to seriously give somebody's
brain damage because the operator was
trying to jerk off while they were trying
to operate.
It
is there hovering over somebody's
fucking house, you know,
try to come down to the bathroom.
This already perverts doing that.
Perverts fascinate me, man.
They fascinated me. Say Blanket.
You just walk up and say hello. They can't
do it. But then they have these needs,
right? So then they got to peek
around the corner. You know,
speaking of Pekin peaky blinders,
one of my favorite fucking shows is
come on over the last five years, um,
I was on a,
uh,
an airplane flying back from Austin,
from the south by southwest
festival. Um, which, yeah,
I can't tell you another time when you
would not want to be in Austin. You know,
I mean, it's great for films in that
type of Shit, but it's just like,
I don't know, man. I don't know
what happened to that city.
I've been going there for the last 20
years. It just gets more and more crowded.
It's like a bunch of sweaty
hippies with LH level traffic.
That's what south by southwest is.
And I don't know what it is.
Every white person in
Austin during that week,
they all look like they play hacky sack,
you know,
I dunno if there's just
something about the, uh,
did disheveled on purpose colleged
age white kid that I know.
I even when I went to college,
I wasn't like that, you know,
fucking combed my hair when
I still had here. Right.
I didn't try to fucking look
like I lived out on the street.
That was like a big guy thing back then
to try to look all fucking disheveled.
Like guy could barely take care of myself.
But look at my college id.
Look at my crazy picture.
It's like, dude, you did.
All of the sudden this whole
fucking thing is on purpose.
The end of the fucking day,
if your back's against the wall,
you can call your mom and dad.
All right,
so fucking calm your hair and put on a
clean shirt, right? You can't, I'm sorry.
Why did I say all of that? Anyways, I, um,
this was my day.
I actually was flying out there at
that day to do the all things, comedy,
podcasts and then fly right
back. So I, uh, I'm like,
this is great.
I've always wanted to go to the airport
and just have like nothing and just
walked in,
you know,
like Leonardo Dicaprio in catch me if he
came every just come fucking walking in
wearing this little fucking,
I know how to fly plain outfit.
That's what the fuck I wanted to do,
minus that outfit. So I put on sweatpants,
you know,
and whatever fucking tee shirt jacket.
And I had my change of clothes and
toiletries in this backpack and that was
fucking it.
All right.
Went in there like a Goddamn drifter and
I get all the way to the airport and I
realize I forgot my fucking wallet.
Right.
So I can't get on the fucking plane
cause I don't have any form of
identification. I don't have my
college id man from back in the day.
And, um, what did I have?
Um,
I ended up having to go,
yeah,
I didn't know what to do. I was like,
I'm gonna miss this fucking fun.
I'm actually thinking now that my dad,
she did grow my hair out a little bit in
college, but I still dress respectfully.
Maybe I was a hybrid. I can't fucking
remember was so fucking long ago. Anyways,
so I fucking get to the airport.
I don't have my Goddamn id and I don't
know what the fuck to do and I have to
make this,
this podcast cause his advertisers
and all that type of shit.
You can't say this is the lineup.
This is the projected amount of
people that are going to listen.
It's a business and then not show up
and take the fucking money. So, uh,
I didn't know what to
do. So I ended up, uh,
the first time ever I flew private
and blue a fucking ton of cash.
So I'm going to be playing a bunch of
casinos coming up to make up for the money
that I, uh, that I spent on,
that I flew out of Van Nuys
like a fucking rock star,
lit up my card, literally glowing in
my pocket. I had to fuck a drive home,
get my wallet, fly out, you know,
drive out there and then sit there and
then talk to these fucking savages just
being like, oh, you need a plane
right now. Ah Yeah, really,
that'll be 1 million bucks.
And I'm like,
fuck you with somebody else.
And they're like,
it'll be a half a million.
I'm like, fuck you.
And all you do is you just keep calling
people and after awhile you just start
saying numbers and um,
I got it.
I got it way the fuck down for whatever
they first quoted me. I have that,
got it down to half that, but still
cost a fucking zillion bucks. So, uh,
I get on the plane talking to the
pilots to like, right fucking,
there was a smaller plane, like when
I went to take a Piss, I'm like,
do you guys have a bathroom here?
They're like, yeah, they do.
When they had to move the snacks and
then they closed that little door and I'm
taking a piss right on the other
side of the fucking door and like,
you can't stand up in the
plane. So I am stand up, but I,
I'm acting like I have osteoporosis and
I'm trying to take a fucking piss and
there's, there's an angle you have to be
at so you don't piss on your own fucking
sweatpants.
But eventually the velocity of the urine
coming out of your Dick is going to
slow down and it's going to
come towards your clothes.
So then you gotta make a decision. What
am I going? How am I going to do this?
How far down am I going to pull my pants?
What the fuck's going on?
Like that weird kid. Remember that weird
kid when you were in elementary school?
You went in to take a piss and the kid
had his pants all the way down around his
ankles. It's like, why didn't
you just fucking on Zip? You fly,
you know what's going on here?
So,
and then old town,
I'm just thinking like,
how is this better than flying on a
commercial airline? I don't get it.
You know what, if you fly in business of
first, if you bump yourself up, um, the,
I am one and done on that shit.
I just think it's the,
it's a colossal fucking waste of money.
And I have the glowing fucking
credit card right now to prove it.
And um,
there's just no money in it.
The fucking people who rent the
planes of barely making any money,
the pilots don't make any money.
All the pilots,
one eventually fly for commercial,
a commercial airline, right? I mean,
they're still flying commercial private
or they want to fly for like, you know,
one of the major airlines
is what I'm trying to say.
So one of the pilots came back and
he's talking to me. He goes, yeah,
we got some beers here. And I'm like,
I'm on the wagon. But I'm like, well,
what the fuck? I spent all this
money, I got to have a beer.
So I drank a cores light, like the
white trash count that I am. And um,
he sitting there talking to me and uh,
I'm all fascinated with the,
all the aviation aspects of it.
And I'm sitting there and looking at
the guy and he had a tear in his slacks
right at his knee. Like
there was a, like a,
like a vertical slice,
like he was in a knife fight and
just so many sliced it a little bit.
And I was just going like,
there's no fucking money in this.
What this guy's doing right now define
the law of gravity getting me from Los
Angeles to Austin. He doesn't
get lost. He knows where to go.
He knows what altitude to fly at.
We had a nice fucking landing. We,
my life is literally in this guy's hand
and they don't pay this guy enough money
that he can fly this fucking jet without
a pair of pants that have fucking
ripped. You know, maybe that's why
all those kids fucking annoyed me.
You know what, he's, I didn't fit,
you know, when I was in Austin,
cause I'm seeing a guy who actually
really is struggling flying of fucking jet
and he has fucking a ripped slacks.
Who knows?
Maybe he just had a rough night. He
had a rough one. Maybe just passed out.
I don't fucking know. Anyways. Um,
I remember when I was in college
and uh, yeah, like I, I did,
I was never that fucking rebel guy.
I remember walking by this chick one time
and I just had like mainstream clothes
on.
I had like a polo shirt and regular shit.
I remember I walked by and she
just goes, Ooh, hot labels.
I just want to be like,
you fucking golf.
Can you look like every other fucking
got caught here? Do you guys all,
I don't know what fucking every blacks,
everything painted black store.
You fucking walking.
You all have the same fucking makeup.
Y'All have the same fucking lipstick.
Yeah. I just, you know, cause
there's no goth food court.
You feel like you're out of the year
out of the reach of the corporations.
I'll never forget that. Ooh, hot labels.
And I kind of liked her too cause a lot
of those got chicks with cute, you know,
if you could get past the fucking,
you know, now a days I would actually,
I would totally steer clear of them
knowing what I know. It's like, Oh God,
let me, I would have one question. Do
you or do you not hate your parents?
You do and say, ah, I'm not
fucking going through that shit.
Those fucking long talks about everything
that they did to you. You know?
And you know what? My parents
did shit to, you know,
and I'm a parent now and
I'm going to do shit.
You know that doesn't mean you got to
fucking walk around dressed like you were
in awake.
Okay.
I mean, why are you dressed like
that? Cause you got bullied.
Now look at you now you're just
bringing this shit onto yourself.
What are you waiting for bullies
to become enlightened and be like,
oh I guess people have the right to be
different. It's not going to happen.
So at the very least,
if you're going to walk around like that,
it at least at some point
take the makeup off,
going to a Dojo and learn some fucking
MMA shit so you can protect yourself.
So I guess in the end of the day,
I'm not really attacking golf people.
I'm really saying a pellet fucker.
She still judged me, right?
Yeah.
Ooh,
hot labels.
I've seen one of those things where you
walk and you kind of stop for half a
second and then you, is it worth it?
It's not worth it. And I just kept going.
I forget what her fucking name was.
It was either Natasha a brook,
which was always a fucking hot girl name.
When I was growing up,
I never really saw a brook that wasn't
good looking. Natasha's were good looking.
Debbie's Debbie's, we'll fund Debbie's
were fun girl. It's weird like you give,
you give a fucking person a name,
you know what I mean? It was, I,
you know, just blending
in. Bill lost in the crowd.
Oh, mainstream bill with this corporate
clothes. Just walking down the street.
I did have the Red Afro for awhile
when I got into fucking radio.
I fucking grew it out
a little bit. And, uh,
I think I had the beard or that's when
I got into drums and I was trying to be
in a band and that sort of,
I was trying to grow my hair
out and it just went out,
which would have been cool in the sixties
or seventies I would've looked like
Bernie from room to 22 but
by the 80s it wasn't cool.
You had to have the law and fucking
hand just never worked for me.
The comedy gods, they just pulled
me in. It's like, listen bill,
you'll look like a douche
no matter what you do. Okay.
You're not a good looking guy. You
look like a fucking freak. Okay.
The only hope for you is to stand on
stage and make fun of yourself and make a
little bit of money. Why didn't you want
to, you cash in on your Orange Afro?
You know, I think that that's what
was going on. And eventually I, I,
that's what I did.
That is exactly what I did.
And then when I was making enough money
in the business, uh, the comedy, God said,
okay, you don't need your orange afro
anymore. And they took it from me. Um,
I know what the fuck I'm talking about.
Oh,
I know what I wanted to
bring up two weeks in a row.
I'm going to give you a great movie.
I told you I saw Jordan peals get out,
which is so fucking such a
great movie. And so, you know,
different from everything
else that's out there.
I'm actually going to enjoy
watching Hollywood now.
Try to rip that movie off.
It's like get out,
meet people who don't know
how to make a get out.
I think they're going to do the
Latino version. Um, however you say,
uh, get out in a Latino, you know,
Salado Vamonos I don't
what the fuck you say.
I'm starting to remember sesame street
and we had to enter and exit Ibn
[inaudible] out. Oh, that
was close. I don't fucking
room. I don't know. You know,
whatever.
There's some fucking white guy will get
a reset of stone and he'll figure out
how to say it.
Don't try to rip off that movie.
That was a great movie. And this week, um,
I was on the plane ride back from Austin.
Wait a minute,
typing in my password and I saw
the guy from peaky blinders.
Kilian Murphy don't know
nothing about no robbery.
Oh fuck you with the fucking password.
Hang on a second. God Damn it.
Okay.
Uh, there we go. It's called, I
don't know, I hope I say this right.
It's um,
anthropoid a n t h r o p.
O. I. D and it's based on,
they say the extraordinary true
story of operation anthropoid uh,
the world war mission to attempt
to assassinate ss general.
I am hard Heidrich.
Um,
and what I love is it, it's a
story I never heard. You know,
granted I don't fucking read and it
takes place in a checklist of Aki and
Prague. And I had no idea. I
knew that Germany, you know,
they lost I guess
Austria in World War One.
And then, uh, you know, a star came back
and he's just like on TV should have that.
And they just took fucking Austria
and nobody in Europe did anything.
And everyone's just like,
well, well maybe that's,
maybe they'll just be happy with that
and we won't get involved in this fucking
world war thing again. And then I
thought he went immediately to Poland,
but evidently, oh, fucking evil.
Charlie Chaplin himself
went to a checklist of,
I had no idea and, uh, made me want
to read up on the subject. And,
um, it's a fucking amazing,
amazing movie. And, uh,
it's one of those movies where,
uh, what they're talking about,
the behavior was so heroic
as you're watching it,
you're actually sort of squirming going,
like,
how would I react? What I would
hope that I would be one of these,
you know, the good guys here as opposed
to the person just trying to blend in.
Well,
they're not coming after me and I just
sort of do whatever the fuck they see.
And I'll choose like self
preservation, which I gotta
be honest with you. Like, um,
I would never fault a parent for doing
that because once you get your kid like
you just like so focused on your fucking
kid, you just like fuck all adults,
you know, not fuck all adults.
It's a cycle. I'm not creating
a situation. Me, I go,
I I think I got a kid,
you know,
but you'd like to think like,
you know what?
Fuck that I'm going to teach my kid how
to shoot a fucking Uzi and let's go Nazi
hunting. You know, you'd like to
think that you were that person
as opposed to sitting there quietly
eating your soggy cornflakes.
You know,
this is the thing about being a
coward is if nobody else knows,
you'll forgive yourself.
You know,
it's other people know and it just
staring at your shoes for the, you know,
waiting for the people that know what
a coward you were during that time.
Eventually die or you die or whatever.
But it's a fucking unbelievable
fucking movie. Absolutely loved it.
And um, directed by
Sean Ellis. I like this,
I like giving shout outs cause not a
lot of people go to movies anymore.
Shout outs,
all these fucking talented people
here and it stars a Jamie Dornan.
Kilian Murphy. I hope I said
that right. It's spelled c,
I. L. L. I. A. N. A. Come on.
You got to have a couple of broads
in here with some 11 inches, right?
I'm never going to say this.
Sarah Amro Savage Strava,
a fried joke joke.
These crisis is like trying to
name a fucking hockey player now.
Hannah F R e J.
K O. V. A with a fucking
hatchet mark right above it.
I Dunno. It was a, it was
amazing. Very fucking movie.
Check it out if you get a
chance. If you're on American
Airlines, it's playing. Um,
I don't know if they get extra money if
they do it that way. I Dunno. All right.
Anyways, let's read a little bit
of advertising here for this week.
What do we got here? Oh, but
oh, due to me on days, Mandy,
shoot a couple of fucking Nazis.
Bodu Dude,
do me on these me undies play and when
you're wearing Yahtzee, ea fucking Ryan.
Fuck off you fucking
balls will feel real nice.
Shave your head if you got lice.
I like me undies on my Tate's.
It makes me have really good dreams.
Oh yeah.
Unlike the generic ones when you were
in Haines, right? Ooh, hot labels.
All right,
me undies.
Okay.
Oh Man. That one's stuck with, isn't it
amazing the things that stick with you?
That was almost 30 fucking years ago
and I still remember it like it was
yesterday. Ooh. Hot labels. You know,
if I had a time machine, like I wouldn't
go back and try and stop Hitler.
I'd go back to that moment in my life
so I could turn around and be like, God.
And that'll be, that'll
be it. That'll be it.
And I get right back in and I would leave
anyways.
Mandy's elevate your underwear
game, your underwear game, yo,
to the next level with me on these me,
you've perfected your wardrobe.
Hey, but what about the stuff?
Not everybody gets to see, man.
If you've been settling for store,
bought underwear,
five packs,
if you've been settling to go into the
fucking mall and buying a pack of five
pairs of underwear that some fucking
kid had to sew together in El Salvador,
if you're sick of going
through that difficult thing,
I have something that will
change your life for the better,
and that is fucking me undies.
What's the first thing you put on
in the last thing you take off?
What does it do? Your underwear, right?
Unless you leave your hat on your
fucking Weirdo, it's your underwear.
Make your most important piece of clothing
the best it can be with me on these.
When's the last time you were completely
naked and you just had on a hat?
You know if there's anybody in the
room, they're fucking laughing, right?
You cannot be completely naked and
just have on a hat and not do a dance.
It's impossible.
Especially if you guy,
then you've got your junks fucking
shaking around. It's tremendous.
It's a great show. Actually. What is
me undies are just seriously soft.
Feel good undies delivered
right to your door.
Mandy's are designed in
Los Angeles or Louisiana.
They don't really say la and made
from sustainable sourced micro modal,
modal fabric,
three times softer than cotton.
Beyond these softer than
soft luxury undies coming in
ever changing selection of
classic colors. What is Classic College?
It's probably your basic, you know,
Crayon set when you're a little kid.
What's your favorite color?
Whoa. All right. Blue, red,
white, black, brown, yellow,
green. That's it. That's it. Like the
original members had guns and roses.
Then all of a sudden you get burnt Sienna.
You know when Matt Sorum comes in and
you get a little fucking, uh, I dunno.
Some mother fucking off white. When
you get a, what does that Guy Dizzy?
Fucking something around there. Anyways,
bold shapes at French tourists patterns.
So you can tailor your undies to your own
personal style. Guess what? Guess what?
You can save time and money each
month with a monthly subscription.
How much do you shit your pants
that you need underwear every month.
And if you're not ready
for a subscription, that's
okay. You can still save.
That's because Mandy's is offering
you 20% off the first pair.
Just use our special URL me undies.com/bar
and get 20% off your first pair.
So go ahead revamp your underwear drawer.
You deserve it.
It will put you in a good mood,
man. New Underwear and new socks.
You know that's like a
body off restoration.
You know you're not just putting a
coat of paint on this piece of shit.
The new pair of slacks, he
going right down and he'll
bowls. Once again, that's me,
undies.com/burr me on these.com/
[inaudible] a better day for your taint.
Tight frame bridge. Everybody. Do you
guys have a bunch of photos laying around?
We'll do you.
You got art that's rolled up in your
closet just waiting for you to put it in a
nice frame to hang on the walls,
but you don't want to
fucking deal with that shit.
Wouldn't it be great if there was
just something you know can call free
bridge.com you can send them all that
shit and then it would come back to your
house. Frank, you can put it up on your
walls and pretend you're interesting when,
that'd be great. Well, you can
do that with frame bridge.com.
Do you take a thousand photos that
never get put on a single frame?
Now you can get those great memories
off your camera on your wall with frame
bridge.com. Why frame
bridge? You might ask. Well,
prices start at just 39 bucks in or
up to 70% less than triff traditional
framing stores.
Go to [inaudible] dot com you choose
your frame from their curated collection.
Upload your art,
preview it before you buy can upload yard.
It's stupid bastard. No worries.
You can mail it in for free.
You're framed piece of art at your
home. Um, arrives at your home,
ready to hang, get your
personal experience using
frame, bridge.com the site,
the ease of order, how your piece turned
out and how easy and affordable it was.
I know I read that wrong anyways.
I love frame bridge. Evidently.
I know you will too.
It's so easy to use.
I just delivered that like walking.
It's so easy to use. Uh, so much,
so much more affordable than
traditional frames stores right now.
Frame bridge.com has a special
offer from chest, from my listeners,
and wherever else they advertise with 15%
off your first order and free shipping
when you use my code
Berg. So get started. Uh,
get started framing your art or picture.
Go to [inaudible] dot com
find your favorite frame
from the curated collection.
Upload Your Art or Male, upload
your a, mail it in for free.
Preview your art and your custom frame.
Enter my code birth checkout to get
15% off and free shipping. Don't wait.
This offer expires this week.
So go to frame bridge.com.
Use My code bur bur to save.
And lastly, but not leastly.
Okay.
Do you like to booze? Huh?
Do you like to get fucked up?
But you don't want to get pulled
over for drinking and driving?
Wouldn't be great if there was a
service that was like a taxi service,
but it wasn't, it was just
some person in a car. Well,
I introduce you to lift l,
Y,
f t cause you can never spell it
the correct way in the modern era,
in the modern era, right? It's gotta be,
it's gotta be funky. Get people over this,
not l I f t man, that's the
squares. This is l. Y. F. T.
Like why would you drive when
you're drinking and um, you know,
you know about Lyft, right? Right.
It's the APP that gets you a
ride in minutes on demand 24,
seven for less than the cost of a cab.
Uh, please include the following points.
By the way,
that fucking commercial,
I think it's full lift that they do on
TV where the people are robbing the bank
and they're freaking out.
And then there's that one kid
just sitting there going like, oh,
the guy's named Tim. That's a great
name. And he's totally fucking relax.
Does that fucking actor in that is,
is should immediately be put in movies.
That's my own personal opinion. I
thought it was very unique. There's all,
I'm saying it's a great commercial bread.
I'll all the way run
two thumbs up anyways,
please include the following points
during your read. Okay. If you tried Lyft,
you know what I mean? Um, with Lyft,
you just download the APP
request to driver and they
show up in three and a half
minutes. On average. That's really fast.
Everybody knows how this fucking works.
Every Lyft drivers fully vetted through
that 10 points. Safety Standard one.
Have you ever fucked the kid? Okay,
good. We moved to the second round to,
have you ever had a drone crash into your
neighbor because you were jerking off
watching them take a
shower? No. Okay. Three.
Yeah. Have you ever been
sympathetic to the Communist Party?
Whatever the fuck they say up to that
it kind of goes off the rails. You know,
once you haven't fucked a kid, you
know, you haven't killed anybody,
then it's kind of like, Eh,
you know, uh, you like to boost
plan. How much do you like the boots? Um,
10 point a standard including criminal
and DMV background checks, you know,
you'll get around quickly and safety
lift drivers are rated after every ride.
So only the best stick around this is
like bill Belichick do your fucking job.
You don't have to worry about getting
into a filthy car with some creepy dude.
With Lyft, you can tip in the APP, which
obviously leads to happier drivers.
So right now Lyft is offering
our listeners a special deal.
They get three free fucking rides,
dude, up to $10 each.
That's up to a $30 value.
If you can't do basic math when you
enter the Promo Code Bill Burr B I,
L L B U R R, all in capital
letters to make me feel important,
just download the free Lyft app today
and enter the Promo Code Bill. Burn,
no space,
all capitals.
You will respect me and
the payment section, uh,
you'll start with three free rides,
up to $10 each.
That's up to a $30 value.
If you have an,
if you do not have the
ability to do basic math,
10 times three is 30 a
that's Promo code bill bird,
no spaces. All capital letters,
enter Promo Code Bilber,
no space. All capital letters. Okay.
You put my names and you put my name and
fucking lights on that goddamn website.
All right, going to go up to out there.
There's may half hour just like that.
Just like that. Oh, wouldn't it
be nice if you would shut up.
I'm going to in a minute. Um, what
do I have on the thing? Uh, oh,
I have a benefit benefit.
Um,
on March 25th and I am for
M ms and it's here in la.
I for some reason don't have
the information in front of me.
I don't fucking know.
I'm co hosting it with Craig Gas.
It's rock against ms I believe is
going to be a bunch of musicians there.
Steven Adler again,
fucking Gilby, Clark, um,
Rudy Sasso, Michael, Devin. All of these
fucking rock stars are going to be there.
We're going to raise a bunch of money to
help try and find a cure for this bed.
Horrific disease as opposed to
what? Bill? A wonderful disease.
What about the disease of laughter?
I don't think we ever want to
cure that to me. I'm sorry.
I'm going to be in San Jose this week.
Everybody, Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday,
I'm doing two shows a night.
I got my new shit going on.
I was supposed to do the
goddamn comedy jam, but I'm,
my fucking shoulder is messed up.
And uh,
I've been driving my old truck to
that's three on the tree and that's the
shoulder that's fucked up.
But I actually was bothering
me just to shift on the column.
That's how fucking old I am.
Like someday I might have to sell that
truck because it hurts my shoulder to
just shift. It only has
three gears. I know.
It's fucking pathetic. I've been fallen
off on the Bruins and the Celtics,
I know the Bruins scored a bunch of goals.
I know we beat the bulls the
other day, but then the, uh,
the Bruins scored six goals,
four goals in the third period.
I watched the first period of both the,
uh,
the Vancouver and the Calgary game.
And that was always my,
my fantasy when I was young as a fan,
when I went on the road, you know,
I was just like, I would love to do
that fucking western Canada road trip.
You know, back then it was
Calgary, Edmonton, Vancouver,
Eh,
maybe played Winnepeg too.
And then the last end he went down
and they played the La Kings in La.
Kings would just sit and way out
in the West would nobody nearer.
Like the closest fucking
team I think was Vancouver.
And then the next closest would probably
be, would have been the St Louis Blues,
maybe Chicago Blackhawks. I will
guess Saint Louis. They would just,
there was no fucking team west of
St Louis other than the La Kings.
So no wonder the answer to that time
took him so long to win a fucking cup
along. They had to fly.
Vancouver's never fucking one.
One Calgary one once, right. In 89,
they'd be fucking Patrick war
in the Montreal Canadians. Uh,
I want to say Pat Burns was coaching
that team. I can't remember,
but Edmonton Limited fucking lit it up.
So anyways,
let me see if they'd be Calgary
Leslie Boston prayer.
We go bro wins. Here we go. Boston Bruins.
If flying around the ice they
saw Pasta Knox 29th goal.
He's really fill in, fill in the
uh, Tyler and void. When you say,
you know,
since Tyler Sagan left,
Marshawn became a legitimate superstar
and now pasta knock is on his way.
So I guess we're doing all right.
You know,
we survived it and I
actually think Tyler Sagan,
all this shown us
congratulating ourselves.
I think we want Bruins extinguish
the flames. You get it.
You get it.
It's like they're on fire.
David Back is returned from a collision
into the boards. Yeah, that was scary.
That looked like me and pick up hockey.
Um,
oh for fuck sakes.
Where did the story go?
We scored the game winner is
the Bruins down the flames.
Five to two in Calgary on Wednesday
we scored six goals of Vancouver.
Five 11 goals in two fucking games.
You know, all my fucking bitch
moaning and complaining. Um,
Marshawn humbled by emerging
status as a lead score. Yeah,
that's absolutely right.
What about pasta?
Marshawn had a hat trick in Vancouver
and I fucking missed it, dude.
All of a sudden we're scoring goals and
I was sitting there wine and saying,
do not get rid of Clo Julian. And
it's been a, it's totally worked out.
It's worked out for us. It's worked out
for him. It's worked out for the Canadian,
so it's all good.
And I'm flying around the ice
with the new coach Cassidy.
That's fucking great. That's
fucking great. I love it. I love it.
Is good to see Doug Hamilton to seem to
be doing all right out there and can't.
And Calgary, I never, I never have
a fucking problem with the experts.
Even if they decided to
try to take more money.
I don't give a fuck you a career.
Have a good time.
Good to see you still in the league.
You know,
I know you're out there in the saddle
dome that doesn't get a lot of love down
here in the lower 48 as they
say in Alaska. Um, anyways,
that's the podcast I got to get on
with my fucking day here. Oh my God.
My wife said the fucking greatest thing
to me ever to fucking motivate me to
work out. I was sitting there looking
in the mirror in the bathroom.
I just fat shamed myself every fucking
night. That's how I stay in shape, right?
And I just,
you know,
I went off the rails and I ate steak and
shake twice and a to Mcdonald's twice
and had burger king.
This month has been like fast
food when had been on the road,
I don't want spend going on with me.
Right?
So I was looking at the
results of that diet
and I was just looking in the mirror
and I, I called myself a tub of fuck,
which I've never said my life.
I was just like, you fucking
soft mushy tub of fuck.
And then Nia was in the other room
going like, what's going on with you?
I don't know. Look at me. I'm fucking, I'm
a mess. She goes, yeah, I looked at bad.
I go, Yag, do look at me. I've got a
fucking dad bod now. And she goes, no,
you don't. I don't need it. You're not
helping me. You know, I need honesty here.
And then she just goes,
all right,
you're not his tone as you once were.
And I just went, fuck yeah. She goes,
I'm sorry you said that. I said, no,
you're doing me a favor. So
that's it. Now I've been on it.
I've been on it like the
Joe Rogan company. I've been
focusing on it. Alright.
Oatmeal. Fucking poached egg
in the morning. By the way,
when you make your poached eggs,
if you want to have them like they
do in the restaurant, you know it's,
it's spooning with itself.
This is such a simple trick.
I didn't even know it for all these years.
Just swirl the water.
I know I've said this before,
but maybe you missed the podcast.
Just swirl the water, get a
little whirlpool going. Okay.
And then you crack the egg,
you drop it right down the center
and it's like a figure skater.
You know when they do the fucking
spinning around and it just,
it brings its arms in and then you go,
you take it out with a slotted spoon,
you put it on a fucking English muffin.
Unless you like me. If you're a tub
fuck and you're trying to lose weight,
there's no English muffin.
It's just sitting in naked and afraid.
That is the dumbest fucking show.
Do you know there's no prize?
These people go out there and get like
fucking Lyme disease got ants crawling
around their balls and up into
their fucking private parts. I mean,
I just don't understand why you would
do that. Cavemen were not naked.
They were definitely afraid,
but they fucking killed something
and they covered up their junk.
I actually saw this guy naked in
a fucking tree with a hatchet.
This is just a commercial
because I refuse to watch that.
I don't watch that show.
You know,
black people will watch shit that
because it's a bad representation of
themselves.
That's what that show is for white people.
There's very few shows out there that,
that bring white people down, you know,
because white people are run and shit.
So we always make ourselves the
fucking heroes. I'm naked and afraid.
That's not a good show for white people.
That is every stereotype of a fucking
white person. Just like, you know,
I think my life is just too fucking easy.
I got to make it difficult.
What am I just took all my clothes off,
went to the fucking juggled sob.
I could survive.
Yeah.
Naked and afraid. So this fucking
guy and just in the commercial Ford,
he's up in a tree and he's fucking
hacking at this branch in this tree.
He sitting in and then the whole fucking
branch collapses and it's just like,
that reminds me of some
shit from like bugs bunny.
We the f somebody be sitting on a branch
in this sign off in a sitting on the
wrong side of it and then they fall
off or the whole tree falls down.
I literally watched this guy do what?
Live action.
A real person did that to himself. He
was, but he was hacking on the right side.
But still, I don't know what happened.
The whole thing fucking falls.
And now he's falling in.
Yeah.
To like a bunch of like branches sticking
all like with just completely naked.
You know,
I never cut my balls my entire life.
I never got a scratch on my balls.
Nothing.
Cause they were covered up.
They had on a pair of pants,
claims a fucking tree naked.
MMM.
Anyways,
I don't know why I'm talking about this.
I don't know why I have this level of
passion for a fucking show. I don't,
I don't even watch, uh, that's the uh,
yeah, checked in on you. Okay. You guys,
you guys have,
you guys have yourself a great fucking
weekend or write your cards and I will,
uh, I'll talk to you on Monday. All right.
That's it. Go fuck yourselves. And, uh,
God bless the United States of America.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's still birth is the Monday
morning podcast for a Monday,
March 16th, 2009. Um,
I didn't know what this is the
year of anybody. Asian listening.
What is it the year of? Is it
the year of the Monkey? Um,
I am in San Francisco right now
and, uh, I can't believe it.
It's drizzling out and it's cold
and it's miserable as just, I,
I just blew my mind because every
time I come to San Francisco,
but whether it's just, it's just, you
know, it just puts a smile on your face,
you know, it's just
one of those, you know,
which I don't know when the fuck they
ever filmed that rice a Roni commercial,
but it must've been like the one sunny
day in the last 10 fucking years out here.
Cause this is the 12th time
I've come to this city.
I just pulled that number out of the air,
but whatever,
it was the suck every time.
And that's like five typically impossible.
Um, and as I mentioned,
I have a touch of a cold.
I usually get sick when I come here.
Dave was actually a little bit sick before
I got here. How did you get sick bill?
Well, I'll tell you, I went to a
Joshua tree national park and uh,
evidently I didn't dress properly as I
hiked my way out to somebody goldmine,
literally, um, Joshua tree definitely, uh,
definitely a good time. Although I made
a real, I made a big time fool of myself.
I showed up and uh,
I asked the ranger,
I swear to God he was a ranger,
but he's working the gift shops.
So I forget he sucks at the and arranger,
you know what I mean?
Probably accidentally started
a fire rather than putting
one out in the park. So,
uh, I asked the ranger, I, you know,
it's called Joshua tree. So in my mind,
you know,
there's this big beautiful park and this
is one fucking Joshua tree and that's
what everybody comes up to.
And you know, like that,
what's that wall at all those
Jewish people go up and pray to?
I thought it was something like that,
some sort of Mecca. Right? So I say, yeah,
you got, gives me a map of
the whole, the whole park.
I'm actually getting embarrassed
telling the story. I actually said,
so where exactly is the Joshua Tree?
Is it like,
is it like one tree?
Is it like a group of like five trees
and the guy's looking at me and then just
the way he looked at me,
I just realized,
I just said probably the dumbest fucking
thing I could possibly say within them
park. And evidently this is what
I learned it in defense of myself.
I am from the east coast,
every gift gently. Uh,
Joshua tree is just the type of tree
and I had probably driven by like 200 of
them on the way up to fucking
talking to this ranger.
There was probably three of them in the
parking lot basically there. But you,
people on the east coast who have,
if you ever go out there,
there is no Joshua tree.
It's just a type of tree.
And if you go to Joshua tree and you say,
so where is the Joshua
tree that would like be,
that'd be like going to New Jersey
and going, um, where is the pine tree?
Like the, the, the pine tree
that, you know, the special one.
And, uh, you know, it just,
yeah, I don't know. You know,
I just got the directions.
I just found out out of fucking get there.
I had no information about it,
but you know, in defense of me,
they should name the park.
Uh, Joshua trees, plural,
not Joshua tree.
It confuses people when they ask silly
questions and then they feel stupid and
then they tell him that we tell the story
on their podcast and they get slightly
embarrassed. Um, so anyways,
that was my week. Oh, you know,
somebody went to the San Jose sharks game
on Saturday night on my way up here to
do my one, my two shows here up in San
Francisco, saw the shark's speed, uh,
the kings in a shootout and
at the game I saw a 50 to 50,
I'd say about 55,
58 year old Guy Punch a 27
year old kid right in the face.
And it was fucking hilarious. Um,
there was this kid he had on this, uh,
Detroit Red Wings, Jersey A's
hat on backwards, you know,
and right out of the gate he's
just standing up screaming shit.
And he was cheering on the sharks.
So Evan, I don't know what happened.
I think, cause he kept
standing up anyways, this,
this chick who was also like 55, 58,
she's got this awful fur coat on,
you know, in San Jose. So you
know, she thinks she's somebody,
I'm sure that's a fancy thing
to do in San Jose, California.
What a fucking ghost town that was by
the way, is that nobody on the streets.
Right. So, um, yeah, speaking of which,
like I actually was going cheap with the
fuck I was going to stay and I actually
, uh, decided to stay at
this Ramada, you know,
thinking that it was, you
know, I'm like, all right,
it's like an 89 bucks for the
night. Fuck it. I'll stay here.
And I pull in and it's one of those deals
where the hotel rooms open up out into
the parking lot. And if you're a fan of
my podcast, you know, I feel about those.
I do not stay, I don't
stay in motels. Okay.
Even if you call it a hotel,
if it fucking opens up,
if your room opens up out into the
parking lot, that's a fucking motel.
Can somebody tell what is the
definition of a motel versa hotel?
Cause if my world,
if your door opens up to the parking lot,
that is a motel slash this serial killer
buffet where they can just walk down
and be like,
I'm going to kill this guy.
I'm going to kill this guy
and I fucking with that guy.
So I never even checked in nor
did I cancel my reservation.
So I wonder,
I wonder if I'm going to pay for that.
I ended up just calling the
Marriott around the corner,
not even worried about whether they had
a fucking room available because I saw
that there was only six
people on the street,
four of which were fucking crack heads.
Um,
yeah. So anyway, so I go to this fucking
game, get back on track here. Yeah.
So this woman, this fur coat, all of a
sudden she gets into it with this guy.
Where is this? This, this Red
Wings Jersey, and you know,
she's giving him shit and he's
given it right back to her,
which of course I'm loving.
You know what I mean?
They're usually guys back down to women
once they start screaming in public and
he didn't, he just kept
giving a shit right back. And
I don't know what she said,
but she goes, yeah, you just
try me. Or something like that.
Which was really fucking annoying.
You know,
I hate where women act like they're
going to get physical with a man.
Like they're going to knock them out.
It's like we do shut up, you know,
I can't hit you.
I mean I could,
but I'm instantly going to go to fucking
jail and then I'm going to get raped,
you know?
So stop acting like you're fucking Tufts.
The law is on your side. I, right.
So she's doing all that shit and he's
given a shit right back and then it's sort
of died down. Then I started watching
the game again and next thing you know,
there's just this commotion and I
look over to my left again. Now,
the kid in the Red Wings
Jersey is covered in beer
and he's John at the,
the lady with the fur coat and a,
obviously she dumped it over
his head, you know, I mean,
of course I would too if it was
illegal to kick the shit out of me.
So she dumps it over ahead.
Any doesn't blast her in the face.
Just adding to her country level that
she's going to be the following day.
The fact that she got away with that and
didn't get dropped. I'm not advocating,
I don't think you should hit a woman,
but I don't feel that women should take
advantage of the fact that a man can't
hit them by just doing over the top
country things like just dumping a beer on
somebody. You know what I mean? So
anyways, so she dumps a beer on the guy,
which I gotta admit is also
hilarious on another level.
So I didn't hear the exchange, I
guess. I don't know what happened.
All of a sudden this fucking old guy comes
into the picture he's got his face is
all twisted up with angry anger, and
he just says to the kid, he goes,
who are you calling a bitch? He must've
called the chicken of fur coat a bitch.
And I, the kid didn't say
anything and I swear to God,
this fucking 55 year old dude who was
the slowest punch I've ever seen in my
life. He literally lifted his
hand up like a rock 'em sock.
'Em robot and just through this
straight, not even, you know,
I don't know what the fuck it was.
It was like rock 'em sock 'em he just,
she sort of bought them right,
right on the nose.
And then the kid just immediately called
for security and I was just like, wow,
that's really a tough situation.
They're like,
he just dealt with two of the
toughest physical confrontations.
A woman dumps a bureau via head. You want
to punch her in the face, but you can't,
but then you allow them to dump it
over your head. So he deals with that.
Then he has an old guy
punched him in the face.
It's like another man just
You want to drill them back but
you can't cause he's an old guy,
but then you will out an old
guy to punch you in the face.
So at this point this guy
socially has been raped, right.
So I'm thinking when security
comes down, I'm like, all right,
this guy got punched in the face and a
beer over his head. He might actually,
you know,
he should get out of this even though
he's younger than the two of them.
You're going to be sympathetic
with the old people.
But he immediately screws up cause the
security gets there and he just starts
cursing his brains out.
Go and I didn't do shit.
I was use fucking watching the fucking,
they just snatched him.
They actually snatched all three
of them and 20 minutes later,
somehow the kid with the Red Wings
Jersey came back and the two old people
didn't. And I was thinking, how
the fuck did he pull that off?
And the only way I can think of it is,
is if the old guy admitted
to punching him in the face,
which is probably what someone
would do if they weren't a lawyer.
He probably said,
well this guy punched me in the face
and then he probably did it cause you
called my wife a bitch and then it
became do you want to press charges?
And then the old guy gets scared and grabs
his walker and he leaves and then the
fucking Detroit Redwings kid came back.
That was my experience.
Was that just a long boring
story that went nowhere.
I kind of lost interest towards the end
of that and their mouth started getting
dry. Anyway, this is the month, uh,
the Monday morning podcast and a,
if you new to my podcast, I do one
of these every single week. And uh,
I think it's becoming really relevant
during these tough economic times,
you know, to just give away
something free like this.
I'm only mentioning that it's free
cause somebody told me that they find it
annoying when people say it's a podcast,
you know,
it's like really? Well,
it is a free podcast.
You fucking douchebag and
despite the fact that it's free,
people still bitch at me
every week, you know? So yeah,
I am going to throw it in your face then.
I'm doing this for free.
What do you think about that? I'm going
to guilt you. Just like your grandmother.
You know I saw one of the greatest movie
trailers I've ever seen in my life.
Do you guys, you guys fans
of the movie the dirty dozen?
Well what is wrong with you have
you should be go go on youtube,
hit pause. You don't need to listen to
me right now. This is all you need to do.
If you want to be entertained for free,
just go on youtube and type
in the dirty dozen and watch.
Watch the movie trailer of it and they
have one of the greatest lines I think
that has ever been written.
And then describing basically
the premise of the movie is this.
These 12 guys who are on basically either
on death row are facing really long
prison sentences.
And if they agree to go on this
suicide mission to kill a bunch of Nazi
officers, if they survive,
they get to go free. And, uh,
that's the movie.
So they're basically describing all the
characters and one of the characters
they described as an Indian with
war paint smeared on his soul.
I can't do it justice.
I cannot do it justice.
The guys doing it in that movie voice
and he's not doing it with a hint of how
fucking hilarious it is.
Cause it wasn't a hilarious back then
and Indian was more page smeared on his
soul. It's just, it's fucking awesome. I
want that as my ring tone. Um, anyways,
so let's get on with the podcast. Uh,
yeah, like if you're new to my podcast,
people send me questions, I answer my
answer the questions as best I can.
People send me their lists of underrated
things they find underrated or
overrated and movie reviews.
Um,
and the latest,
the latest is people are
telling me stories of, uh,
of revenge. Uh, all right, so
here's one. They're really long.
These people really are writing me like
Stephen King length stories of revenge
and I'm personally, what I've been saying
throughout this is I don't do revenge.
I, uh, I enjoy hearing the stories,
but I don't do it because a,
I just, my Karma is too
fucking strong. I Dunno man.
Like there's something about
revenge unless it's face to face,
you know, you just sort of
fight somebody, you know,
that seems like an honorable kind
of revenge. But when you sort of,
you start the second year,
like looking at another human
being and they don't know,
you're looking at them and you're
trying to plan some diabolical shit.
I don't know about you guys,
but there's something inside of me.
I can't fucking do it because I
just, I never feel more evil. I mean,
I'm not gonna lie to you.
I've sat around and thought about it,
but to actually carry it out. Yeah.
Who knows? Maybe it's exciting.
I never feel more alive than when plotting
the death of a, my next door neighbor.
All right, here we go. Um, you
know that sound byte, Mike,
to come back to haunt me in the future
when I pull my Robert Blake in my sixties.
Take that one out of context. All
right, so here's the podcast one.
I'm gonna try to skip through most of
this and just get to the gist of it.
A pill. I was going to college
in Washington state, uh,
but I'm skipping all of my classes
and getting horrible grades.
The school I was going to was university
of Puget sound easily the worst place
I've ever fucking been to a
Yada, Yada, Yada. So anyways,
there was this kid who was a friend of
mine and at the beginning of the summer
he was in front of his at the
beginning of the semester.
But I slowly started to realize
that he was a piece of shit,
which culminated when he also
having red hair fucked my then
girlfriend when she was drunk.
That makes sense. So basically he had this
friend in the beginning, the semester.
He thought he was cool.
You graduated,
realizes that he's a piece of shit in
the culminated when he fucked his then
girlfriend when she was drunk.
There we go. So anyways, uh,
uh,
what he said was this,
this was actually one of the better
moments of my time at the college hearing
that they had hooked up and finding
her the next day, the next morning,
sorry. And she literally
could not look me in the eye,
which in hindsight I find extremely funny.
Um,
and she is shame she and an shamed way
explained that she thought the other guy
was me, but she was so
drunk, she didn't notice.
They look to say I was not understanding
with her at all and may be out of
character choice to go back to not
fucking anyone. Well, good for you man.
It's a strong choice. Hey,
go be alone. Good move. Um,
but this of course ended my friendship
with that piece of shit kid since he
confirmed what I had been suspecting about
him, about big being a, uh, an asshole.
So Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. This. So
basically the kid stops going into class.
He starts drinking every day
and he ends up dropping out.
So, uh, he's cleaning out basically
his room. He goes, so it's my last day.
I'm happy, I'm happier than a crack
head with a hundred dollar bill,
packing my shit up.
Then the cock sucker who fucked my
girlfriend somehow found me in the hall
checking myself out of my room and he
comes up to me with this incredible
Shitty,
shitty eating grin and he says how much
he's gonna miss me and that thickly
sarcastic tone.
And then actually proceeded to pinch my
cheek like your grandmother used to when
you were six.
I'm sure you know the feeling of shaking
with rage, being unable to do anything,
being unable to do anything.
Assaulting a kid at a liberal arts school
with security guards right in front of
me would get me arrested.
But of course I still felt like the
world's biggest gaping pussy for not doing
anything at all. Something had to be done
about this. And here comes the revenge,
ladies and gentlemen. Uh, okay.
I decided I liked the kids, uh,
from the ranch story last week,
I decided to fuck with his
car. Yeah. Jesus Christ, Dude.
You know, that's, that's really not,
that's not the man. That's not the,
the, uh, that's not the John Wayne
move there. You know, you should have,
you could have always gone back when
the security wasn't there and then just
sorta, just fucking smashed him in
the face. You, I dunno. So anyway,
he decides to fuck with his car.
Dude, you're reminded
me of that. That, uh,
that chicken fast times at Ridgemont
high, that's what, what's what women do?
They write dick or prick on the
side of your car or whatever.
What am I going to do? Well,
I'm going to stop judging.
I'll just read the rest of the story.
So he had decided to fuck with his car.
He had a nice Jetta and I knew
where he parked at every night.
So I got a friend to be my lookout as
much as a scumbag as I am for fucking with
someone else's car. All right.
At least he admitted it. Uh,
this could not have gone any
better. Miraculously, there was,
there was this perfect gap in the security
patrols given me just enough time to
key every panel on his car and slash
all four tires until I was back on the
sidewalk with my friend. Uh, immediately
up to finishing security guard showed up.
Bill old people started doing
their early morning walk to Cetera,
and I got the fuck out of there.
Within an hour,
I caught a bus to Seattle and commerce
started working almost immediately.
Only an hour in front of
my friend's apartment.
And hour later in front of my friend's
apartment, I started feeling awful.
I went from feeling totally fine
to having a, a hallucinatory fever.
Uh, I lay in my friend's bed for an entire
day until around four when apparently
that Jack has discovered what I did to
his car and called my phone over and over
from a number from his number, then
from all my friends' phones, etc.
I don't remember much of,
is this conversation,
but I do know I was trying
to be a tough guy. Uh,
blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah. So the kid kept calling
for months and months. Eventually I
stopped answering his calls, but he,
he kept calling, dude,
you fucked with a cycle.
You know, when he came up and pinched
your cheek like that, and they said,
how much do you do? Realize how, what a
sadistic fucking maniac you dealing with.
It's probably good.
You didn't fucking punch him cause
he probably would've came at you like
Hannibal lector and fitting the
Chunky a cheek right out of your face.
But anyway,
he said,
he even called me on Christmas almost a
month later when he would call it these
times, it's always on available,
blah, blah, blah blah.
Oh, this is a good party. I'd answer.
And he'd start making heavy
breathing noises after awhile.
Like those telephone perverts
women were afraid of in the 1960s
a story has a happy ending though.
Uh, at one of those hipsters bar,
a sort of gothic coffee shop.
Actually I managed to hook up with a girl
that was probably out of my league by
playing off his constant cycle phone
calls as though there were other chicks
trying to get with me.
I don't know whether,
does that sound like the number one thing?
Well, it's like with revenge. I'm sorry,
like that was really choppy,
but I swear to God,
the kid wrote me like a manifesto.
I was really trying and I don't have time
to edit these fucking things, but uh,
that seems to be people's
number one a way of uh,
taking revenge on somebody.
You know,
you got to get out there and uh,
fuck with their car.
I guess that what's makes it ven right.
Revenge has to be sneaky.
Bye.
See,
wait a minute.
We've got two guys fuck with a car
and we had another guy who took his
girlfriend to Disneyland is ex-girlfriend,
have cheated on him and did
horrific things to her. Ah,
you know what it is about revenge.
It has to be sneaky because even that
chick thought she was going to Disneyland
to ride on the tea cups and to get back
with this guy and he was actually taken
her down there to, to make a porno.
Um, do you know something that that's,
that's what it is about revenge.
I can't deal with,
I can't deal with the dishonesty of it.
There's just something that just makes
you feel like, uh, he just feel dirty.
You know, he fuck up somebody's car.
You should do it right in front of them.
As you look at them with some
maniacal look on your face.
I mean that would really, you know, when
that get them, cause then you'd be like,
wow, this guy knows I'd fuck
him up if he fuck with my car.
And not only is he doing in front of me,
he made sure he called out my name.
So I saw him doing it.
You know what I mean?
Got It.
You know what their minds me on what time?
I saw this crazy white dude on the subway
and he was rapping some song and that
had the n word in it and it was like
10 black people on the train. Okay.
And he's dropping the n
bomb every five seconds.
Okay.
I like, I'm a crazy
Edward, some something,
some crazy and we're doing the best
they can. And then he'd go, whew.
He just kept doing it over and over
out of his fucking mind.
But why is hell all the downtown six
back in the day when I lived on the upper
east side, he kept saying it over and
over again and it was like, you know,
was a subway. It was like 10, 15 black
dudes on the train who was a white dude.
He's dropping the Edwards. Every white
person knows if you fucking do that,
if it's instantaneous asking.
But I think that that's what saved him
is because he was so overtly doing it.
All the black people looked at him.
We're like,
this guy knows we're going to kick the
fuck out of him yet he's still doing it.
So then you do the quick
math. Oh, he's fucking crazy.
He's crazy.
Okay,
I'm going to fight this guy and he's
going to bite me and I'm going to get
hepatitis. So that's the, uh,
I don't know what the fuck
point up front and make that.
That's how you get out
of, I guess, you know,
not getting your ass kicked because if
you can truly convince people that you're
fucking crazy, like people
just, they, they, they don't,
they don't mess with you.
So that's what you should've done then
did you want to keep this fucking car in
front of them?
They just have a maniacal look on your
face and every other sentence just scream
out. Woo. And they leave you
alone. Anyone after dealt,
dealt with the phone calls and then
again you wouldn't hooked up with the
chicken, the coffee shop. I don't know.
Let's get to the podcast questions.
Shall We? I get a, I get
fucking, I get a cold here. Okay.
I'm making excuses for that last two
minutes. That didn't even make sense.
All right, podcast question number one. So
you talked about wanting to have a kid
now, now that you're getting older,
I'm just curious to know if you would
want him or her to hear your podcasts
considering you can don't
things like revenge.
I love how people don't listen to me.
I don't condone revenge.
I've said that on every podcast,
but I do find the stories interesting.
And I will comment and laughed
at the shit that you did.
I don't condone what Scarface did,
but I can enjoy him shooting up people
in the end of the movie, you know?
Anyway, so he, but anyways, the way
this guy heard it, maybe I've maybe out,
you know, maybe I wasn't clear about
what I was saying. So anyways, uh,
the way he heard it is basically I condone
things like prevention. He said, I,
he busting a nut on your x space to make
her feel like a whore for cheating on
you.
I'm not criticizing you.
I'm sincerely interested in knowing
if having a child will change your
perception on things
because as I close in on 40,
I'm feeling the same way,
wanting to finally have a kid and it
makes me consider if I should adjust my
moral compass beforehand because I would
want my son or daughter to have me as a
decent role model. Your situation is a
little more precarious in the your future.
10 year old son could find an old
copy of bill burrs. Greatest hits.
And here I was,
father thinks that common a girl's hair
is the best prescription for heartbreak.
Keep up the good work.
Ah, all right Michael.
This is how I view this type of shit.
Um,
for me to actually think about anything
that I'm saying on this podcast about
actually having a child that I don't
even have is the quickest way of making
these podcasts horrifically. Unfunny. Um,
um,
I actually,
I have major problems with parents
and how once they have kids,
they all of a sudden start acting like
they're not the fucking frat boy date
rapists that they used to be.
And not only do they act that way,
want everyone else to behave that way too,
because they knocked up the check
that they're with and it's like, dude,
I did knock up my curl. Okay. I'm
still having a good fucking time.
You know what I mean? So if
my, you know what, why don't,
why don't I do the rest of his
pod, this, this moment right now,
like my future 10 year old son is actually
listening to the archives. Hey son,
what's going on?
It's your dad.
I hope I didn't fuck up the first
10 years of your life. Listen son,
if you're taking anything that I say
on these podcasts remotely, seriously,
I've completely failed as a parent and
I want you to go outside and fall on a
fucking lawn dart.
Cause I'm going to start over again and
I'm going to make another kid and a,
I'm the teaching them to learn how
to fucking take a joke. I don't know.
You don't want I got halfway through
that and just got fucking creepy.
I just told him my future kid
to kill himself, you know,
with a toy that has been banned.
Um, no, to be honest with you, no,
I never, I never think about what
you're asking me. Do I swear to God?
Is the formula for not becoming funny?
You know,
that's what comedians
do is they get older,
they have kids and all of a sudden they
stopped cursing on stage and they stay
one of the role model.
And uh,
that's when shit just starts going
down hill. And, uh, you know,
you want to start doing family
movies, you know, and, uh,
I'm not doing that. Okay. I'm a comedian.
Nothing I say should be taken
seriously if you take it seriously,
if that's not my problem.
Uh, even if you are my kid,
I'm be honest with my kid.
You know what I mean?
Now people like try to shelter their
kids and tell them that there's a Santa
clause and everything like that. And
you know, I don't know about that.
Like if somebody does something
really weird and then my kids like,
why did somebody, why did that person
do that? I'd be like, you know what son?
Because most people are cons, you know,
I know it's a harsh reality and uh,
enjoy your coloring years sun,
cause it's only gonna get worse.
I wasn't going to get worse.
All Right, Bill listening to,
uh, okay, bill listening to
the newly discovered podcast.
You all, this is the guy. You
know what? This guy, I'm going to,
I'm going to say this guy for this,
this right here. Not as whole email.
But this email right here, I think
this guy earns Douche bag of the, uh,
of the fucking week because he goes,
you should charge for your podcast and
up the production value or just leave
them as they are.
Just don't keep mentioning that they're
free like other podcasts is due.
It's a bit Douchey when you do that.
You know what?
Why don't you go fuck yourself? How
about you do that? Is that, do she,
if I tell you that you fucking cunt,
they'll tell me what to do in
this fucking podcast is free.
I don't need to do this.
Shift going to tell me how the fuck
I'm supposed to do these. All right?
So go fuck yourself on
your first paragraph. But
because I'm such sweetheart,
I'll read the rest of it. The
rest of it. You don't bug me.
You're a Douche in your
first paragraph. Uh, Bill.
So with the Vinny call you to come in,
I kind of assume you are a drummer
like me and with the headphone comment
drummer headphones gotta be
right. Uh, I've got to be right.
So if you are a drummer and listen
through headphones, listen to Steve,
Steve,
oh seven days,
then in parentheses it says a sting
field with gold. All they did,
they did a cover of that. Yeah. I don't
know if you guys listened to the podcast,
but that's I'm kind of into,
I've been starting to buy records.
I started buying them again and uh,
find like some concept albums and that's,
you know,
those all those great old albums.
So just a great, somebody sent me,
somebody wrote something on the
Internet where they would just,
they were bitching about music today
and they said something to the effect of
how,
you know,
how bummed they worked because people
today don't want to hear good music.
I just think that's such a hilarious
comment. People today. Yeah.
They don't want to hear good music. Oh
yeah, that's, that's exactly what it is.
It has nothing to do with the deregulation
of media in the early 1980s which
allowed fucking five guys to buy all
the fucking radio stations and to run
everyone exactly like the other one.
Thus limiting the amount of
music that can get on the radio.
That's not what it is. It's that people
then they don't want to hear the music.
Is that good music? You shut that
off, Mr. I don't want to hear that.
I want to hear some awful, I don't
want to hear good music. You know,
it's funny, there's the cleaning ladies
on the outside of the door and she picks,
I can't hear. And I know she's
listening to me ranting it here,
debating whether or not to come in
here or not. I know you're out there.
Um,
John just freaked around.
Kind of freaked me out too because I
realized that technically I really am not
talking to anybody. Um, what was I
talking about? Oh yeah, the music.
I think there's plenty of good
music out there. You just,
you get access to find it.
It's on the Internet now and
possibly on satellite radio.
And if you don't have satellite radio,
that's one of the most
underrated things ever. Uh,
it's fucking incredible.
And I'm getting it put in my car because,
uh, I've rented a few cars recently and
they've had satellite ready radio in it,
and that's where the good music is.
That's where the funny radio shows are.
That's where it's at when it comes to
radio. Man, it's fucking great. And uh,
and people curse on the radio,
which I enjoy.
And if I had a 10 year old son,
I let I let him listen to those words
because I always heard them from the day I
was walking around. I heard him and look
at me. I turned out fine and I did two.
Stop laughing. I did pay my fucking
taxes. I'm not hurting anybody.
Um, anyways. Overrated.
Underrated. Uh, overrated.
This guy says sonic youth.
Dot, dot, dot. Really?
You know what? I don't know. Are they
the ones who are saying a runaway train?
How about the kids who
runaway runaway Chelsea?
I would call it back.
[inaudible] something
Yak. Ah, Paul Simon. A.
Dot dot. Dot. I want to shove an African
drum up his ass. Is he black now?
Okay. Listen to any Paul Simon album
in the late eighties, early nineties.
Do you ever think he was just trying to
expand as an artist and he was working
with different musicians and he
went outside of America? You know,
it's not like he went out there with
a Fubu fucking a tracksuit on when he
played with them. Notice I said
Fubu staying at times with the, uh,
early nineties was Fubu, wasn't
it? It was at midnight. You know,
Jesus Christ who did the black,
now he's standing next to a black guy.
He's still wearing those wrangler jeans,
those awful hair plugs.
Uh, BB King, the other
guy says is overrated.
He's been milking the legend
status for so long. He can't eat.
He can't even play a chord. C
You two's rattle and hum, dude,
I got to agree with you on
that one. Bb King, I think.
Uh, yeah, I think he might be a little
overrated. The guy can't play a chord.
A, he does play nicely,
but a, if you've noticed,
there's not a lot of black people going
out to see them. I think it's a pitcher.
White people who think he's good.
That was one of the most ignorant fucking
things I'll ever say that really made
me laugh. You know, and that guy who
sent me the email, I didn't mean that.
So in the future, when my 10 year
old son hears it ease, I, you know,
he's going to know and let Jesus Christ.
Why would you put that in my fucking head?
I never think shit like that.
That's how you know,
if you think about ramifications,
you never going to be funny.
Hey, what if I say this?
Won't that hurt someone in the crowd?
And then the moment to set it is gone
and it's over five batch shows tonight.
I'm going to fucking blame you. Hey,
like that. Alright. Underrated. Uh,
the Mayfield four miles. Kennedy.
I have no idea who that is.
I'm going to look that up.
And Roy Orbison,
he's one of those guys who
is overrated and underrated.
I think he's underrated with the
average listener. And he's overrated.
When you talk about him, about
his, uh, seven octave voice.
Hey,
I dunno.
He really has an amazing
range with his voice,
but I don't like the sound of it.
Is that like sac religious list?
Some of the songs he
thinks like pretty willing
[inaudible]
yeah.
[inaudible] you.
Oh, kill yourself. He looks like a
lesbian. All right. Underrated. Uh,
the slight Enos of college chicks.
Um,
I don't care. Well seeing a Roy
Orbison, he died out of nowhere, man.
Like I just had a heart attack.
That's one of those guys where
he dies of a heart attack.
You really look at his face and it's
like, yeah, I can see the heart attack.
He had a blue cheese double chin,
underrated the sluttiness
of college chicks.
I don't care where you went to college,
if you lived any,
if you lived away at school and
weren't getting laid once a week,
something must be wrong with your Dick.
This is over exaggerating a bit.
That's one of my favorite expressions.
I think I've ever read over exaggerating.
I'm trying to do the math on what
the fuck that means. So if you said,
if you lived away at school and we're
getting laid at least once a week,
if you weren't getting late,
at least once a week,
something must be wrong with your Dick.
But that statement is, is overexaggerated
over it.
So does that mean you're not exaggerating?
Does that mean to get laid
one and a half times a week?
You tag someone and finger bless someone
else. I really don't do sex jokes.
I believe that that makes
me uncomfortable. Uh, but
this is over exaggerating.
Vimpat ice still. It is ridiculous.
I went to a small Catholic college,
but you would know about the stories I
got from my dorm room. A couple bears,
some can't even read this.
Do you guys even guys like against using
the space bar? A couple of beers, some
dim dorm room lighting and slow jam
playlists off your laptop and you were in
business most of the time. It didn't
even matter if your roommates were there.
I want to have my roommate wake up to
this bitch sitting on my face riding a
unicycle. All right, we're going to
stop there. Okay, I got it. Dude,
you're getting late.
Jesus Christ.
You know what? That's actually
true. I never lived at college,
but I definitely hooked up with college
girls and I actually hooked up with the
girl in the top bunk and her in a
roommate now only was in the bottom bunk,
but was awake.
I have you ever tried to fuck
respectfully in respective kind of way?
It doesn't really work.
Uh,
especially when you use a word you
can't even pronounce respectively.
Does that even, does that even
a word? All right. Overrated.
Adding why to the end of guys' names,
unless you're playing stick ball in the
school yard or your grandma calls to
wish you a happy birthday.
If you're over the age of 18 year old
man and should not be referred to as Joey
or daddy or any other bullshit name ending
and why I'm hoping you would want to
punch. The first guy walks up and says,
hey Billy, what's up? It's bullshit.
You're a man. You should go buy a man's
name. You know what? That's exactly right.
I actually,
when I first game game into this business,
I went by Bill Burr and I thought it
was too short and too difficult to say.
So for like five years I went by Billy
and even though it flowed better with my
name, anytime anybody called me that
I, it just, it, it didn't feel right.
It was just like a,
unless the guy was some like New Jersey,
they have a way of making it sound. All
right. Are New York guys, but it's just,
I just felt like a little kid.
Like I should have been sitting there
with my brown sack lunch and after,
I don't know how Billy crystal does it,
so I would have to agree with
you on that one. All right.
And I think that's it. I think
that's it for the podcast. Uh,
I want to thank everyone
for listening this week. Uh,
it's a little bit on the short side,
but um, I don't know. It's weird.
I'm up in San Francisco and I
got a gig tonight and I want,
before I even do the Gig,
I want to thank everybody for coming
out on a Monday night. I know it's a,
you know, it's a work night for you guys.
You working hard and that type of shit.
So, uh, listen to this.
Before we come onto my show,
I'm going to try out this new chunk and
I'm probably going to bomb, but, uh,
definitely going to give
you your money's worth.
I really appreciate
everybody who showed up
or who's going to show up or if this
is the next day who has showed up?
Jesus Christ, they'll get to the point.
And on next week I'm going to be at the,
uh, not this upcoming weekend, the
following weekend, last weekend in March,
I'm going to be at the, uh, uh,
the house comedy in East Saint Louis.
All the information's on a
billboard.com and anything else?
Oh, and I'm going to be on
the opie and Anthony Show. Um,
when I got, I got to Atlantic City
Day covenant. What is the fucking day?
Hold on one second. I got to
figure this out. I need a calendar.
God dammit.
Hang on a second.
He knows podcast from school and
pretty smooth up until this point.
This is just garbage time. You can hang up
right now. You don't do this. All right.
The Trump marina gig is on April 4th.
All right,
so that's the Saturday. So
Friday the third, second,
first, the first, second and
third. At least someone would go,
I'm going to be on the open.
Anthony show him going back into New
York and I'm going to visit my, uh,
my good friends, um,
opie and Anthony and uh,
they always hilarious little Jimmy
Norton and I'm really excited to get back
there. Um, it's the number one thing
that I miss about living in New York.
I fucking loved doing that show.
And uh,
it is on XM satellite radio because
satellite radio was the shit XM two o two.
And uh,
I'll be doing a taping,
an uninformed episode
with Joe de Rosa and a,
and then is it, I think that's it. Oh,
also be at the lake
shore theater in Chicago,
Illinois on April 3rd look amazing zag.
And across the fucking country,
not right. And that is it.
You guys all have yourself a good week
and God bless the United States of
America, say no to the marrow and the
North American Union and microchips.
God bless you.